I don't know if I'm more excited about
this project or he is but remember
um a few Vlogs ago where mobra went on a
trip and I was telling you guys I have a
super fun project in mind that I think
will be really good for his ADHD and
it'll be a great bonding experience and
it was I'm gonna have him draw on a big
poster board whatever he wants and then
we'll go to Home Depot buy the supplies
and build it and make it come to life
well that day I didn't realize that
Margaret was coming back on a Sunday in
the morning so we didn't have time to
rather obviously spend some family time
together but
the day is a free day and since then
which is a few Vlogs ago maybe a few
weeks he's been asking almost every day
so I'm like all right today is our day
and we're gonna do the thing and marbles
also home so we get to do it together
and make it super
CUNY petuni
monkey
[Music]
do you know what's gonna happen today
we're gonna build our big secret project
are you ready Mia
no
a monkey how come you're walking like
that
my butthole hurts your butthole hurts
why is your Buffalo hurt
what happened monkey
you say you didn't wipe it good he
didn't wipe it good oh
we'll go slow does it feel sticky in
there
or is it itchy
or does it feel minty
[Music]
oh my God my poor little hooties butt
butt
look how luxurious the shopping cart is
it's a shopping cart but they know they
got some big kids now that they can't
really fit in here
so yeah you got straps all the way back
here
baby I want to have a baby brother you
can put him there baby brother and then
we have a big we have a bigger brother
it's holidays here and then I can sit
here yeah wait what is happening well
first things first monkey
how is your butt butt much better good
job Mama Pro tip parents yeah always
carry alcohol what does that do you put
me on his what you could put it on his
butt I put it on his mouth well put it
on his cheeks will you put that
everywhere yes it's fascinating you can
use it it's fine cracked skin irritated
skin for some reason in my mind I
thought it was like ChapStick and I
thought you're just rubbing it on all
the holes I was like what and that's not
my problem how your brain is so little
look you see you just got a little bit
since he's trapped here I put this but
you can clean this butt first right
she didn't just put that on there
I knew I did something wrong
that thing looks like a limousine from
this side it's really cute look at this
he looks like he's pushing it too oh
that's CUNY no hold it
hold it look at the steering wheel
oh there you go
um
he's driving it it looks scary like he's
driving it
excuse me it's the best view ever I
don't know where we're going uh we're
going to the supply section okay okay
monkey first things first we have to get
supplies do you know what supplies we're
getting no we have to get a big poster
board look at that oh you just wait come
closer come closer
so you're gonna draw whatever you want
on there it could be a house a giant
fish a car anything and you can put as
many colors as you want and then we're
gonna build it to real life so first
here's poster board have you ever seen
poster board before
this is poster board right here look how
big that is and you could draw the
biggest picture ever
so let's see let's use
yeah let's get this one this one no
that's uh that's different has lines on
it let's get we only need one of these
are you ready to get one of those it's
ripped is that okay is it yeah oh no now
let's get another one
okay put this in the cart make sure you
don't bend it
because that's our blueprints not back
up
all you put over there
that goes more space
okay now go back over there
put it here are you sure it's gonna fit
two of them okay yeah we got two of them
just in case
you never know with kids you know you
could rip on the way home you're
preaching to the choir baby
they could rip here too
okay monkey Next Step whoa whoa don't
get distracted Next Step Mr Monkey dude
we got a project to do okay next up we
got to get markers
get markers yeah
let's get
those markers and that's it that's step
number one
step number two we go home and draw
whatever you want
what's that
this is
brain malfunction no that's the only
supplies we need you know why
because the biggest look at me because
the biggest supplies is at Home Depot
that's the biggest supplies we want to
spend the time building it where we get
the wood and the screws and the glue and
the nuts and the bolts and the Hooves
and the booze and the whoa whoa whoa
okay this is turned into something else
don't get distracted
okay monkey ready for the next step
the first step so step number two is to
draw but you're not gonna draw out the
markers first we're gonna draw with a
pencil to make sure we know what we want
and the mama can help you do you know in
your mind what you want and then you
color it exactly you're smart
yeah that's how we do homework okay very
good and I like how you put the markers
he dumps it like he was a burglar
everything's a money back so do you
understand what you what the assignment
is can you tell me what papa wants you
to do
um drawer in the comment yeah but what
are you gonna draw like what are you
drawing for
come on Ryan
a dragon and then make sure it's big you
see how big this paper goes all the way
here so draw it as big as you can
and then mama can help you too
and then I'm gonna make that
and then I can make that
wow that's weird it looks like a giant
banana huh another banana you want to
erase it
'll be curious maybe mama can help you
oh the dinosaur oh yeah turned into
something else maybe you're doing a
dinosaur
remember the dinosaur looks like what's
the name of the dinosaur that's the
pointy back stegosaurus I mean that
looks like a Stegosaurus it does look
like a Stegosaurus have this yeah oh
this is a tiger source
you know what I like
I like he makes no mistakes he's like I
want to draw a dragon all way it's a
dinosaur
cool this is oh I love it those are some
really cool feet
between adult to adult mama
I'm looking at that and I'm like what
materials do we get to get a shape like
that already so this is wood that's yeah
it's got to be claws are like a wire
okay
this is gonna be like metal okay it
sounds dangerous heavy gauge wood or we
could buy roof shingles something that's
like that shape and then just glue it on
right oh that's really cool yeah
those triangle feet can also even be
like
um
traffic cones
oh God how big are we going I wanted to
make it at least like three feet tall
like life size oh dang I wonder how much
this is all gonna cost I have no idea
but it'll be fun was expensive dude
it'll be cool it'll be a cool uh piece
that we put in the house
anything else you want to add ladies
need a tail a pointy tail a boy detail
kind of like we're right where it is too
whoa you got spikes on his tail too
time to color
what you're doing dude
let's go straight up in the middle
while he's working on that over there
it is lunch time
so I'm working on the lunch and since me
and MOB are on the same diet now
um I'm eating a pretty healthy lunch
that's still decently delicious so I'm
making quesadillas so we got these guys
right here these are not bad it's only
130 calories only four grams of fat so
we're only gonna have one of those I got
my 96 Ford ground beef that I always
have on Deck so I made one of these guys
with about six ounces of beef then I
found these fat free cheeses which is
awesome throw these on here so each one
of these bad boys I should have about
50 if not more grams of protein and all
wrapped up in under like probably 400
calories which is super good so I'm
gonna throw these in the toaster oven so
the funny thing about taika is that he
doesn't like cheese unless it's on Pizza
which is crazy because as a kid I love
the cheese so he can't be eating the
quesadillas with us but with the same
ingredients that I meal prepped I can
make a quick fried rice so get some of
this rice that ground beef crack an egg
throw some kimchi sesame oil bada beam
bada boom lunches served for him as well
boom
what did I just say
okay
that's that cranial attitude right there
it's looking good Mister real clean
just like that got a fried rice with
kimchi ground beef sesame oil some
garlic salt and that should taste pretty
good I mean it smells really good
so we got lunch
[Music]
smell his it actually smells really good
monkey are you okay
yeah okay what's wrong mister
disgusting what do you love fried rice
yeah but not but she's like there's no
cheese in yours but I'm gonna try it try
it
is it good really good
come on Mom sit down okay mister are you
done with your dinosaur yeah okay tell
me about your dinosaur what we got going
on
[Music]
oh my goodness so that's what we're
gonna build yeah
yeah actually and I need a tree
we'll put a tree on there yeah so your
dinosaur gonna be all green did you want
to add any other colors on there no no
okay it's whatever you want it's just
I'm a score house a squirrel's house
because they they come from the same
period
Jurassic Period okay
Esther trees are green
okay so that's what we're gonna have to
build guys a big green stegosaurus is
that a face
is it happy face yeah and he has a heart
yeah because that controls his body yeah
and he has a little bit of yellow in his
tummy area
lime green okay it's a little bit of
lime green okay that's what we'll do
okay monkey
this is now the fun it is Home Depot but
this is the funnest part you know why
because we get to get all the materials
that we need
to build a dinosaur and when it's just
Papa and monkey we ride in a way
different way with Mama Mama does it the
Safeway Papa almost crashes
oh my goodness this is not a car this is
a Weird thingy it's a weird thingy
so you know what I'm thinking
looking at this dinosaur
that we we drew or you drew I'm thinking
the best way to build that might have to
be wood what do you think
either wood or drywall because you can
cut it into this shape
and then we can paint it green
well yeah I bent this look and carry
this poster what do you think about that
idea
leave it straight because
this is big that's true I didn't know
there was going to be cards this big
okay
yup that thing so this thing monkey what
I was thinking is we can use this as the
base see we have a saw horse
so see if we have this yeah we could put
this down like this and then we can buy
a big piece of wood to draw the sides
like that and then we can nail it to the
sides so the dinosaur can stand up what
do you think about that you like that
idea
okay so now we gotta find a big piece of
wood that's big enough for the side of
this dinosaur see that
you have to pick the one up and then
measure you have to put it right here so
all this two tall of us too big then
that means we have to put it away we
need a size like this yeah well we need
a big old dinosaur wood yeah because
this is big yeah we need a big old wood
because we want to make it this big look
how big that is I want to make it as big
as that yeah
because that's a horse body there was no
face
all right so the dinosaur body is
complete
we needed a big piece of wood to go on
the sawhorse right and we got two of
those guys so we can draw it out I have
a jigsaw at home and I can slot into
that shape what Mister bad boy bad boy
this
is which horse is dead
yeah
the people jawed on him with sharks yeah
uh oh you dropped the Gatorade
so now we're looking for the spiky thing
that goes on the back of the dinosaur's
back and tail and I'm just trying to
look for some triangle shapes and I was
like oh that caught my attention imagine
we just cut all these off but these
things are freaking 20 bucks each
so that's gonna be a lot of money I need
to find something that's like less than
a dollar if not
that's pretty cool oh it's a nice sound
[Music]
really good in trouble we're gonna get
in trouble dude I'm gonna kill him what
so we didn't want to tell anybody about
our secret project
but we had to huh yeah only just one guy
because the other guy so you said
where's a triangle thingy and then why
didn't tell the guy I'm gonna tell that
time yeah because we needed help so we
uh had to show our drawing to someone to
let us know where we can find some
triangle shaped stuff to work as a spine
and these might work or maybe some
sheets of these plastic could work we
can cut it out yes
there's a color pencil in there
why I think that's to draw stuff with oh
is that a knife that's a knife that
makes it easy scoring for scoring no
that's not what we need but this is a
plastic section so I'll look around in
here and see if we can find something
that works
no that's metal that's metal used to cut
plastic but this is rubber that is
rubber
monkey
now it's the funnest part you know what
it is we're gonna get paint because
what's the color of your dinosaur green
and then what's the color of this
please it has to be green so I'm gonna
buy spray paint and we can spray it when
we're done
like that have you ever used spray paint
before no I don't only get a paper no
we're gonna use spray paint that's gonna
be really fun you're gonna love it
like like a minute off metal and there's
painted yep
exactly
ones rainbow yeah but the dinosaur is
green
yeah but we got a rainbow and then it
can be way better than other ones who
made it but we gotta stick to the green
one next time we'll make a rainbow
dinosaur
both
you have to have the code okay so but is
this for you yeah what color is it that
in color is that the color is that the
color is it the darker color
um the lighter one okay let's see and
then there's that one too which one do
you like better
oh yeah that one the one you're left
okay
okay can we have another one I think we
might need two of them two
perfect thank you so much you bring it
back
okay okay say thank you
let's go
yeah yeah we can we're gonna buy them
look does it match that color
making that yeah
another dinosaur that dinosaur that's
gonna be cool
wonderful out of what